I'll be gun boy I forget what do I
usually do I do man the radar that's
right all right I'm ready
do I have power to the engines oh yeah
that's right that's my job too
okay we got this we got guns and we got
shields thank you kind sir
I can stream snipe and see the radar on
your screen with a 15 cent those things
on the side aren't gonna hurt where are
we going south south five o'clock bubble
four o'clock not anymore
nineteen out straight six that's not
dangerous you're calling enemies or
gonna there's no enemies okay okay all
right path Oh enemies 5:30 and at two
two o'clock and five on top of that clam
dude yeah God where the clam did yep
working on it there's a lot of clam
going on here
all right to pass both go same way looks
like cave right side or go and this is
the hermit cave no this is not the
regular old cave at ghosts oh God ghosts
Wow they explode oh that really hurt
okay we got a pickaxe what does the
pickaxe - no keys keys okay Keith wait
diskeeper torsos for arms I think my
pickaxe is like digging money out of
found a thing you did look at that look
at the month wait how did you get over
here
magic did you roll the head did you run
ahead of everybody for defense over to
see with a hat uh hi captain who's cold
take me deeper and who has no name are
we all in the same name yeah isn't that
creepy is that creep is he called take
me okay right you have different names I
remember now take you deeper you [ __ ]
edge Lord yeah well you know we wouldn't
have to have a third if you just trusted
in the game developers to fix their
security loopholes all right everybody
in here we go
enemies seven o'clock two enemies you
can
three Emmys pass direct blow all right
you're gonna curve around bare left and
then go straight left path levels off
opening far left I see a fish way off
the left there's no it's not an enemy
it's just a fin I shoot you can if you
want yeah it's a friendly I didn't know
there were friendlies friendlies are
they hey fish weird he's cool seeing you
guys fart sounds yeah I don't I don't
like this sounds they're making but oh
my god there's so many of them they're
all following us even though they're not
attacking they'll help us if we get into
trouble be nice stay with us fish
friends yeah keep go straight down fish
friends Caves bottom right all right
bottom right it is seems like there's a
lot of less split paths like there were
before which is kind of nice yeah this
is simpler at least early on it's nice
to have it simpler too
I don't the big skeleton men early
access out its out access the access is
early at out yeah absolutely chests up
here I swear my pickaxe if I pick axe at
corpses they they spit out gold how Wow
oh my god careful with the ghost yeah
the ghost I need he'll wait help help
help help I don't see you yeah I well
yeah I'm kind of dead 5 inches away from
you guys remember I have weird issues in
this game Wade you suck because you play
on a 4k screen why do you do that mark
come to town you can buy me the whole
setup you want me to have I don't think
I'm reviving him yeah I don't I don't
know if you could revive me
maybe you can't cuz you have the medical
thing oh there we go
God Wade you a competent buffoon yeah if
I did get corpses I get more money look
at all the money I'm getting from the
corpses actually yeah oh there's a
cleaver here way do you want the cleaver
I don't have a backpack you do you we
started with backpacks
oh that's why gave us thanks man I got
it bro yeah thanks for not healing me
when I was dying
I'd listen man you weren't anywhere on
my screen because my 4k monitors too
powerful yeah as I was saying before I
think you
feign being technologically inept so you
get people to take pity on you and they
get so frustrated that they're like I
will buy you something that hasn't yet
happened is this all part of my master
plan yeah it's a long game all right
who's ready not me I need to sleep first
all right ready
no okay let's do it I'm gonna go sleep
you're you go fly blind oh we got that
may have been a mistake
quit all the squids yeah yeah there's a
there's a abandoned ship I'm coming for
torps Oh
squids trouble we're in trouble
I'm going to ship try to go to the ship
so what is this garbage with this ship
no hello go who shot who why Bob did you
shot him twice
he seems cool hello travelers okay well
I woke up this morning got scary I
watched some seaweed grow and pictured
myself holding a bottle of rum I said
sorrow to my mate over there okay sure
sure
the end oh it's a ghost story cuz maybe
a ghost these guys now why would you
kill them you know what happens when we
kill civilizations me one of them
cleavers I give him my cleaver yeah oh
yeah give a cleaver and see what happens
we can buy a new gun gun that is I'm
trying to share mine I don't know wanna
try it
sure I'll contribute okay you contribute
how do you do it
is it E I think yeah you hold the yeah
okay it's a yeah I'm out of coins
someone could come here we go
to the raffle I'm really glad the ghost
didn't mind me shooting yeah that was
good yeah real good yeah
did you not realize it was under
undersea civilization oh I thought we
were fighting some pirate oh no all
right looks like we're coming up on the
pauseboys Leviathan - where is it done
right it's right there hey that does a
lot of damage that's pretty good
Oh keep dodging yeah dude rude ooh
that's pretty good Oh
Oh God okay all right all power to guns
good good all clear all clear there we
go oh [ __ ] no no dinner okay light skin
oh never mind we get dinner yeah we're
doing a dinner hopeful for me Paris so
you can read now wait so they figured
depths you want more guns if we have any
spare power we do not run a faster
turning and that's right with the lights
okay we got poles split path left and
right left is a boss is a boss cave do
we want the boss we can probably dig
them get some good gear all right get
ready to jump out and fight
[Music]
oh he just squeezed him you oh yeah is
oh man he's painful okay here we go back
into it oh we gotta go got the go spray
he's gonna grab he's gonna grab I'm
getting money out of him oh yeah yeah
I'm gonna take all the money out oh he's
got drones oh I'll grab yay he's almost
out good that's pretty gross laughs wait
thank you mister guy this is hurting
real bad you please put me down why is
it that putting me down he holds on for
a long time we can't shoot his arm from
this angle I think if you shoot his arm
it helps I'm dead okay cool that's fine
just chill out just make sure we Frick
god I hit got hit by rock up up above up
up why are you up what is this I don't
know why I'm up I don't know what this
is always up here got it why are you up
here
I don't know what I'm up here if I need
some health wait if you could help wait
cellmark what did you get I don't know I
don't know what this is
grindy do yeah it might be like a water
pump or something like that like it's
possible yeah that working yeah I'm
gonna think whoa no never mind it's a
thing
it just shot an electricity thing oh it
like charges up yes oh it does oh my god
it does what the [ __ ]
NAB Oh mark do a thing watch this
oh it's like an EMP thing EMP nonsense
yeah pretty cool right pretty cool all
right here we go then I guess bullet
rate fire or pollute bullet fire rate
increased okay cool that's good all
right here we go okay master we're gonna
get sipped again all right enemy do five
o'clock as soon as we get down do four
o'clock coming up on three by the time
we level out on them that's okay keep
going
Oh split path looks like hermit cave
directly below that's probably good this
is not a hermit no no this is a hermit
cave I think
Herman hopefully yeah yeah mr. Herman
well that's not a cave then is it don't
give a ciggie I'm standing back trash
that's trash
shake out some trash oh wait wait touch
me touch me touch me
wonderful I wonder if this skin like
supercharged are you don't think you
don't think do you I don't know
nope doesn't do it wait yes did I got
resourceful what really oh oh wait oh my
god this is the greatest thing ever
dude are you kidding me I just
supercharged the engines oh sure that is
pretty amazing
ya know what oh my god engine charge oh
my god this is the greatest thing I've
ever seen ever keep that [ __ ] charged
all right well I'm gonna do my best
it doesn't last long no but it does help
okay
radar oh yeah sorry I wasn't paying
attention oh yeah you guys got it under
control
this is the coolest thing I've ever seen
because it allows me to actually take an
active role in running the engines
shields overcharged chillin we're clear
at the moment yeah 54 55 4 there we go
yeah I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to look at radar and do this at the same
time for like the over church oh my God
why are we bouncing around like oh my
god oh we're taking lots it's keep going
away from him wait keep going away from
me I'm trying
we just need space I just keep going
right into more no back off then you
keep going down down more stuff spawns -
I am particle infection and I am dying
super quickly
I'm drowning there's a hole in my room
okay
yeah go for it this cave is okay
civilization don't shoot anything up
there was like no good way to go that
was you Wade that was that was very
clearly impression of you I was just
talking like a normal
mark did you wake up on the [ __ ] on Wade
side of the bed today I don't like this
guy no these guys are concerning yes
fine what's wrong with that we could
work on buying this gun together maybe
which guns have 84 kosis armor
there's armor look like hull armor it
would be more hull oh wait this is the
shotgun Bob don't you love this one the
shotgun is fantastic we want the shotgun
to the whole armour Oh
shotgun I think right Bob I don't know
up to you it's it was really powerful on
that one run all right I'm putting all
my money towards I'll put all my money
we actually haven't enough yes we know
the gun will replace our current one
what are we stupid my money disappeared
real quick ours everybody shared now no
not when you spend it didn't even
thousand wait that's the right portion
for two thousand you know you didn't ask
if we'd had that you said do we have
that and then no one responded and then
you just spend we could buy it someone
said to go mission said we could buy it
I kept asking if we have enough money I
don't think we do I think we do if kripp
puts money in I think he's out of money
how was he out of money what is [ __ ] has
160 coins left what I have 85 Marcus 59
no I'm empty
no no that's ping you bought the first
game no you didn't buy the first gun I
chipped in half for the first gun Oh
unless you put some money into it see
Bob this is this is a problem you are
all morons and I am disappointed all
right way that's why I literally asked
five times before anyone's anything can
we afford it can we afford it can we
afford it nothing I feel like there's
someone else we can blame in this
don't you even [ __ ] look my way we
got you you're the one who spent money
before we were agreed just buy it what
do you mean don't look away and no one
said anything and then you were like
someone said go for the shotgun that's
not I haven't filled like that's not
what happened I feel like I know I
always say this but I feel like weight
is truly to blame in this Oh boss boss
oh boy I don't know what a barnacle hive
is but uh it's a big mind looking thing
in the center I think how much health do
you have sir just keep shooting straight
down I think all right good job guys
good job
whatever's happening out there it's good
good stuff is it yeah it's dead it died
all right gonna watch out for whatever
else may have spawned in here well done
guys I love this energy church I love it
really cool yeah I feel like I actually
have a role down here now you know
whereas before I would just have to make
it up and hope that you guys thought
that my job was useful when in actuality
I was doing nothing to contribute I was
just calling out random numbers the SONA
was pretty useful yeah well I mean if I
was actually looking at it I was and I
was looking at porn
you're just and stuff yeah saying things
why is your repair up yeah why do you
ready let's do it all right
supercharging engines just said it was I
just I just said oh this is new I didn't
just say bright Bob I said I just said
that he literally did well you said new
area no you meant like a new okay we're
moving into a new place now in a new
zone I think that like the area itself
was a new place we've never seen oh gods
100 swarms of things what's it looking
like
only we had a shotgun if only we had the
shotgun but we don't need the light
anymore do we know what we're up against
I have an idea I believe I can keep the
shields online just with my gun and I
can keep you guys with speed and gun
power with dedicating the energy to it
okay this sucks down here so there's a
play point of no return we're gonna get
sucks yeah looks like the Wright was a
boss this sweet Jesus oh wow oh my god
Oh hold down here okay all right good
job
I am so boned against those things all
right we already have the potion guy
well I don't want any of it you guys now
all four rows do anything for us I can't
even pick it up yeah I think since we
already have and we do have great
already actives what it says ready I am
ready
all right and no snake ease we don't
have fields up there you go yeah I'm
boosting you're working on it I don't
like the sound I'm hearing
oh I sure wish I knew what was going on
out there don't worry about looking I'm
looking I'm like it's fine out here I'm
so good down here okay you got a boss
cave to the left and a regular cave to
the right the way you're going is the
regular cave okay stay with the boss
cave what what what we are what that is
actually you know what I'm not surprised
that is so reflective of your
personality would you RA do not deviate
from the path kind of guy wow I think
that says a lot of things I hope that's
a compliment I mean it's not a
compliment it's just an observation on
your character Oh completely true 100
percent accurate observation on your
character I'm not arguing it is the way
things are and if anything changes it
you will not budge you will stand there
in the path of change and progress sold
out into the worst place I could have
fell down into you mean the place where
we are buddy yes it's terrible down here
it's really nice we're just treasure
chests man if only the one person who
was responsible for healing everyone
else was with everyone else appreciated
he would still be there no you are a
your stick the road kind of guy
discovered press R to view sea monkeys
in the vents de forest there's more fuel
right there it's only happening for me
yes whatever I saw the relics thing pop
up but I don't know where the relic was
oh you just hit R to read it it's like a
lower thing see monkeys in the Vince de
for yep who's ready I've been ready
deviate from it is this a Boston
no that's a civilization that's a circle
that's a city that's a city shoot it
don't shoot it why would you okay we
definitely don't have enough time for
anything this time
unless it's 1200 I guess yeah they're
pretty have you guys I'm just going up
forever
she's like you there we go alright 750
750 mm yep it's not happening does
anyone need a gun we can afford the gun
we got me yeah we got Bob he's
practically a gun look at him I've
always said that about him he's
practically a gun parentally the gun Bob
I think oh you mouth you dirty good gun
I'm human
guys what am i referencing do you get it
ha ha ha everyone references that yeah
what know you were a gun for a second no
okay fine here we go no I have no idea
what the hell you're a long excuse I
don't like that guy
what you heard me Friday Wong yeah
you're being called out man
I'm gonna tell them how much you hate
him tell them I will tell a Bob said
that yeah well no warning that we're
going to a boss okay we're killing it I
don't know what that's supposed to be
but it's a really terrifying sea
creature I didn't see it like brainy
flowers you see it I didn't see
described it like literally described it
if you took an octopus and a donkey and
then drew something unrelated to either
of those my health back up instead of
repair up this time nice all right I
keep getting max health up no matter
what I do I'll trade you for some health
mechanical mechanical abyss all right so
we're gonna need light yes
I mean maybe we'll
it's it's all sepia tone in here sepia
I don't sepia like I mean no I mean I
think you said it right but I'm like why
is it sepia is in the matrix sort of
just monochrome I guess but some yellows
I'll give it to you I'll give it to you
okay I'm actually going to take away
from gun for now and keep shields going
no idea what's coming
I don't know why are you going towards
that what is that I don't know
don't get in the spotlights destroy
those from afar I remember that oh you
remember that yeah yeah we've been here
before yeah well it it's the thing I see
that I don't remember being here dude
it's a thing come on
I hope the boss is close I don't want to
be here any longer we have to be in the
way you're moving makes this really hard
to shoot well I'm trying to stay close
enough to even shoot but not get in the
suck ease
I think he view gun it to the cave I
think you'll be fine oh alright if
you've got it
have you got it on damage you gonna take
away guns Mac shields all right okay art
get to the game oh it's a Herman I shot
the hermit no you shoot things way too
frequently hey look it's the same gun
cool good job at least it was an escape
from that thing
okay here we go like what device lights
lights lights we're being shot oh my god
blows me oh that's a big tent to go in
my face see inside of us all right good
work good work
thanks thank you thank you that was
directed to me right I didn't mean it's
YouTube but then I
oh [ __ ] oh man oh god oh god oh god
we're shooting at everything
oh god I'm in trouble there's a vacuum
cleaner I'm gonna try to shock it Oh
inside of me okay i'ma go take a nap
wait mark for god sakes no no I'm fine
apparently there heal yourself thank you
you know something I was gonna heal live
good wait did you just take I was at one
hell he'll be did a couple times you're
at least at three oh my god I wave you
see why I think you're out to kill me I
am now but like I wasn't before yeah why
now why now why now
no reason oh yeah no reason all those
dull those clips I saved on Twitch what
nothing why would that make you out to
kill me horrible things you say to me
that's why what oh that makes sense okay
that make that makes awesome
yeah wait I really like your new
hairstyle
okay except yeah it's up there
well I didn't know that was gonna be
down here I've got no we've got nothing
- no we've got nothing nothing of what -
no we do this or put on sonar do you
want me to stop doing the electricity's
we really need a pilot go up go up go up
go up go up go up go up go up go up go
up go up
hey wait I figured you to go up and down
I was yelling go up Oh
go down go down go up go up okay okay
fine what are you guys doing around here
where are we cramming up against a wall
Wade cuz we need to [ __ ] know that's
what I want him to do okay there but I
need a moment to kill all this [ __ ] okay
I'll give it to you I'll give it to you
there's a cave directly below you it's
clear now yes it should be right now I
think there's a cave before then yeah
there's a cave directly below that's not
in the quake wave so then we'll have a
laser on us Eliezer and we'll get it
when the time comes and I get some
snacks like Honey Smacks err got more
fuel and from the fuel happy pilot who
just creates a bottle of something keeps
losing us all our fuel instantaneously
at the minor most minor of things
winners are really great hey heal me
heal me heal bot hey I'm just gonna use
this hatchet from now on I don't really
feel like you hey hey hey hey do your
job
heal me really want to do my job anymore
I'd rather you die
oh you'd rather I died see I knew you
were out with me oh oh oh oh wish
someone would heal me
this would be a great time for someone
to prove that they would heal me oh oh
oh oh oh wow that's funny how you don't
heal when when I need heal I'm sorry
wait I'm sorry can we can we reconcile
and I don't want to fight anymore I
never started to fight but I mean well
okay are you could be an [ __ ] about
it recognize that I'm trying to
reconcile with you you do you know I
take it back I don't want it anymore
yeah that's good I'm not feeling me on
nine I don't understand what's happening
thanks for healing me nerd oh that's a
landmine Oh what my max huh Bob I think
Wade took all the treasure what we
literally share everything and this
treasure chest is empty up here that I
just got to think Wade took all the
treasure wait
Bob wait I think Wade took all the
treasure where it was that mark broke
against me today because this feels like
middle junk Minecraft period again here
wait I think we need to change jobs okay
you should go in and I'll Drive because
the driver seems to attract a lot of the
ire I'll Drive
you make shoots kripp is reloading torps
for you much better than aim at this but
I'll do it
okay you ready you ready here we go we
really need some lights
yeah lights are for losers you screwed
me if you can't pilot without lights Bob
then what good are you how do I remove
the guns without up and down up and down
that's all right how I shoot space mace
I don't like that we're asking about
jobs I sort of had a student that you
done this before I didn't realize you
didn't know oh wait give me the guns
back why don't you know how to do the
guns even like thirty years
Oh shipping forever I still know how to
do it yes you see what I mean Bobby see
what I mean Bobby see why I think we
should throw Wade overboard I always
have to gun the only one who I would gun
you if you had charged I am aware of
what I have but I would gun
I mean well you never have before so
I've gone before
did you see the thing no what happened
no I wasn't looking big there was a very
large thing is this a civilization
symbol is it do not doubt it's harder to
kill people with a sword than a gun oh
yeah these are like the ball by 5:06
there's something over at 1650 and it
looks very technologically advanced that
looks like it has to do with shields
possibly Oh
[Music]
MP recharge upgrade oh we never use the
EMP yeah let's say for something else
then there was like some engine looking
thing on the other side I don't know
okay what is this engine speed boost
torpedo turbo we don't really need that
[Applause]
ready
no Bob you said there was somebody you
said there was something but being
outside there were something quite large
oh well like flights I'm aware of what
lights mark light I know here take some
thank you hope you choke on it that's
not very nice joke Oh what is the
Ambassador I don't like it I wish I
could see what it looked like it's so
far below you Wade there's nothing to
even see but
trying to watch the lasers wait was I
actually kidding yeah you're hitting it
yeah you're hitting so let's just snipe
it stay off my weight I can snipe it
from here okay I know the angle yeah
yeah just keep keep doing that yeah keep
doing it it's it's basically dead center
in between these two sides of the wall
why did you let that happen wait why
didn't you dodge it Bob if you have
anything you'd like to say I listen to
you
Bob can you tell Wade that I think he's
a giant piece of mom and dad Bob could
you tell Wade that if he doesn't
understand how to exit a level by now
there's no hope for him no I will not
tell him that is cool I guess we don't
need lights here oh are you guys outside
no you're on the controls okay I got it
it's like kind of dark but you can see
right no that's okay as long as the
enemies aren't super dark yeah it should
be fine I'll give you another boost to
gun there Bob because you deserve it you
you're the true hero of this of this
ship Bob you can see we could see how
this goes all right well I can't hear
I'll I'll zip zap zip the lights every
once in a while are you guys hearing
this is what are you hearing something
am I going insane oh wait we very
carefully enemies are invisible
Wow trigger B no that wasn't Lea MP that
was not the B MEAP I can't do anything
oh my god I don't know if that's good
mark it's fine it's fine spy spy I got a
repair Oh two holes in my room trust me
that was that was a good move okay cool
good all right let me let me guess I'm
just gonna hold space and try and find
the invisible enemies wait wait wait I
want it what can you access the radar
while you're piloting the ship how would
I do that space no space is how I boost
okay okay just checking
I don't know if they pop up on the radar
I'm going down here but I can't see all
that well possum I'm seeing this being a
water for China water for China not a
water vagina or anything but the water
birch honest I don't know I'm gonna have
to drive into these flying things how
about you don't do that dude I'm just
gonna have to go through it sucks it's
fine guys you guys are just being big
bubble-blowing babies about everything
wait I love you are you dying no I'm
fine all right what do you want oh
nothing okay there's no strings attached
to that I see enemy oh wait that's
called flying directly into it that's
called going not evading it in any way
oh sweet Jesus oh that pyramids glowing
red now and there's something green
behind it yeah somebody hit it then I'm
in bad - hit it
I don't know how okay I'll get it then
here let me get off of it how do you do
it you don't know that you go up and
steadily oh the doors got broke oh we we
need much help
guys we're dad down here me and Cooper
dad died we're not dead collectively
though
well that's true [ __ ] is that yeah
welcome to my dad I'm trying to I'm
trying to how the freakin I'm not able
to rez you all the water it hurts by the
way the water hurts real bad can you hit
me a bunch can you hit me a bunch please
yeah thank you okay gonna where's the
leak I got to go get the leak first oh
I'm gonna hit the EMP again it's not
okay oh [ __ ] it's not charged azzaman
charging oh god okay well we're just
kind of boned aren't we
where's the other hole I don't know
where the other hole is up here okay
it's down there okay I'm going for it oh
god I gotta fix this okay I'm fine I'm
fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I don't
know why I can't rez you see if I if I
crouch here usually that would resurrect
you right okay they're trying to get me
right now so walk until you see the
little resurrection thing and then
crouch on us mark what's coming for ya
oh wait I almost saw it I think it's a
problem because you're by the the EMP oh
it pops up every once in a while no crap
I'm gonna just hold it down as if it's
one for you I see it's fine
no oh jeez yeah you try to resin I'm
just gonna try how are they I think
they're bugging out on their hit boxes
or something can you please hit me a
bunch wait oh thank you hey buddy come
this way oh oh god it hurts so bad I'm
going to bed oh yeah you you go to bed
you go to bed yeah they they don't want
it done let me try my EMP gun I don't
know if it'll hurt him but oh it hurts
him okay it does hurt him maybe this
will be a little better one more get
down there with them okay three two one
Oh who's gonna be fine all right guys
this will eventually be okay I don't
know I don't know if this does any
damage if it rises on them that does
damage I mean like comparatively to just
hitting them with you yeah well it might
be a lot less who knows who knows I'll
keep trying it maybe they just have
stupid health hey I was shooting them
with my flintlock and they wouldn't die
so good just invincible is that why they
say yes cuz they're like yeah oh wait
one down one down one down no I'm good
I'm good wait if you want to try to chop
them you can another down instead okay
all right well you coward you're coward
running away from the problem and I I
think I think lots of you for that
little bit keeping you alive I know I've
been fine having babies job damage the
medics job to heal haven't even been
getting damaged because I'm not good
because I'm so much better than you
there we go Wow money what is hurting us
down here something's down there that's
invisible that's hurting us no I think
so yeah I'm just gonna zap my zapper and
see if it hits anything mighty first I'm
gonna run down here no no what yeah
right inside one I do not see any lights
he's by the lights isn't the same same
thing as before
yeah same creature I see him on my
screen he's he's a little he's between
the love okay I got one health I'm oh
she's on our he's on our dead bot
okay well he's down here I see em I see
em okay I'll just use my zapper and
wait'll chop with reckless abandon okay
well there's two down here Oh God I see
two I see you like little digital
glitches sometimes one screen to the
left and ones way in the bottom right
yeah there's one standing on top of our
dead bodies and one in the bottom right
are you seeing me hit him at all you're
not even down here on my phone okay in
the right corner both of them they can
reach you move left a little
movemove there and there on the EMP
right now oh there's a third one right
to your left oh my god why are the three
what is this I don't know this is fun
this is fun I gotta I gotta get the EMP
charging again is it like we killed them
we killed them in real life so now
they're ethereal forever or something
like that I know maybe it's okay because
we probably can't revive me crap anyway
yeah yeah I think this might be game
over for us ending now with a bang but
with a whimper here wait I'm gonna give
you power just drive into the nearest
thing that'll kill us so we can actually
get like a game over what the way you
revive people is you just let them kill
you
yeah you just squall that's true yeah I
guess we can just let them kill don't
why are you wait why are you healing me
I'd kick him up like this yes you can
easily plot your cleaver wait die you
all know balls yeah we don't get
progress because it was a game modded so
there wasn't even any point to that oh
you know wait I feel like we've grown
closer in this experience mm-hmm I feel
like we are two souls blending sympatico
all right